étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
devant le bar
les voitures habituellement vivent la vie la
vie des voitures habituellement c'est deux trois
semaines et euh
notre idée qu'il faut faire des voitures plus
vite
et qu'on fait un buggy par deux ou  deux
trois semaines environ
[Musique]
travail étranger [Musique] [Musique] maintenant parce que
d'abord, comme je l'ai dit, je suis crémeux et
en lambeaux et je veux rentrer chez moi, je
veux rencontrer ma famille et c'est ma
motivation interne pour le faire
[Musique]
merci
quand elle est morte elle n'est pas morte sur
place il est mort sur la route de l'hôpital le plus proche
mais le problème était que l'
hôpital le plus proche était à 150 kilomètres
donc en gros si quelque chose comme ça
aurait existé alors  peut-être qu'est-ce que ça
aurait été une chance
[Musique]
étrangère